Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Schon gehört, Facebook heißt jetzt Meta.
Na dann benennst du halt die Meta-Ebene um in Face.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, Nummer 411 vom 29. Oktober 2021 und da sind wir wieder und es sind aufregende Zeiten und spezielle Zahlen stehen im Raum, überall und es sind Einsen und Nullen. Schon wieder Linus, Einsen und Nullen. Oder ein A. Das stimmt auch. Je nachdem. Choose your Zahlensystem. Auf jeden Fall gestern, der 28. Oktober, das ist nämlich quasi unser Geburtstag gewesen und jetzt gibt es Logbuch Netzpolitik seit zehn Jahren.
Ich frag mich halt, wie du ernsthaft, wenn du den Typen siehst, auf die Idee kommen kannst, dass der noch nicht genug hätte und du da noch irgendwie was zu beitragen musst.
Ja, warum werden Obdachlose überfallen? Also ich meine, es trifft ja immer schon die Schwächsten. Und das kann man sich ja genauso wenig vorstellen. Und es sind die Flüchtlinge, die sozusagen alles verloren haben, die dann irgendwie auch nochmal oben einen drauf bekommen müssen. Und das ist eigentlich immer dasselbe Ding. Und Leute, die etabliert sind und stark rüberkommen und Geld haben und Beziehungen haben, denen passiert sowas halt nicht. Und natürlich fahren die jetzt irgendwie nicht zu Herrn Höcke, auch wenn man vielleicht mal seine Adresse als die neue Wohnadresse vom Drachenlord rausgeben könnte. Da wäre ich wirklich mal gespannt. Dann treffen die Hater mal richtig auf die Hater.
Also kann ich dir sagen, warum man sich dem Anwesen von Höcke wahrscheinlich lieber nicht nähert, weil er wahrscheinlich sofort irgendwie in hooligan Trupp bereit steht, um dir auf die Fresse zu hauen. Also ich muss mich da jetzt noch mal einlesen, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, hat die Staatsanwältin sogar jetzt auch noch Berufungen angekündigt, weil sie die Strafe nicht gut genug findet. Er hätte sich gerne eine höhere Strafe für den Drachenlord gewünscht.
Ist sie nicht diejenige, die das umsetzt?
Nee, es ist Richterin, die das macht.
Ach so, ich habe es verwechselt. Staatsanwälte möchte noch mehr drauf haben.
Sie möchte gerne noch mehr drauf haben. Also du fragst dich wirklich, was haben die denn da? Also es ist wirklich irre. Es gibt ein Video, in dem er das auch mal sagt. Ich glaube wirklich, das, was sie dem angetan haben, das hält halt kein Mensch aus. Und auch wenn ich jetzt sicherlich nicht die Inhalte irgendwie besonders interessant oder erstrebenswert finde, die der verbreitet, begnüge ich mich einfach tagtäglich mit der Option, irgendwas anderes zu gucken. Und so sehe ich wirklich nicht, was die über die Jahre mit dem gemacht haben. Du erinnerst dich hier dieser, wie heißt die nochmal, diese Imp und Dorian, dieser Arschlöcher da. Die hatten dem ja dann irgendwie eine Frau dahingeschickt, die dann Tateilswesen den verliebt und dann hat der im Livestream einen Heiratsantrag gemacht. Und in dem Moment hat sie dann gesagt, du bist irgendwie ein hässlicher Wichser, du bist der Ekelhafteste, den ich kenne. Und dann haben sie sich darüber kaputt gelacht, dass sie den verarscht hatten. Weißt du, ich mein, das ist einfach, das ist alles so unterirdisch.
So unterirdisch und unwürdig und verachtenswürdig, was die Leute machen. Das geht gar nicht mehr.
Das ist so niedrig, ey. Und ich frage mich wirklich, was denn so Menschen los ist, die dann irgendwie auch noch da sitzen und quasi als eine Aufwertung ihrer selbst oder als witzig oder sowas wahrnehmen. Also wirklich echt kranker Shit.
Dafür fehlt uns leider jetzt die intellektuelle Kraft, das noch zu verstehen.
Naja, Impfpässe sind gefälscht im Umlauf. Also das ist irgendwie noch nicht so ganz klar, was da los ist. Also die italienische Nutzer sind irgendwie im Besitz von Impfpässen, die also sehr offensichtlich nicht echt sein können. Irgendwie ein gültiges Impfzertifikat für Adolf Hitler geboren am 1.1.1900. Offenbar ist mindestens einer oder mehrere geheime Schlüssel abhanden gekommen, mit denen andere in der Lage waren, quasi dann beliebige Impfpässe auszustellen. Es ist noch nicht ganz klar, wie das passiert ist. Ich hätte da mehrere Hypothesen, aber es ist offenbar geschehen. Wir werden sicherlich auch noch erfahren, wie genau das passiert ist. Das Spannende ist jetzt, wie gehst du jetzt damit um? Das war etwas, was wir hier auch in der Sendung behandelt haben, dass du dich auf jeden Fall auf diesen Fall vorbereiten musst, wenn du eine PKI baust.
Also Public Key Infrastruktur.
Genau, also eine Zertifikatsinfrastruktur, mit der ja diese Dinger signiert werden. Die Zertifikatsignaturen sind ja das, was den gültigen vom ungültigen Impfpass unterscheidet. Und die Hierarchie dahinter ist so ungefähr, es gibt dann eine EU-Ebene, dann gibt es mehrere Mitgliedstaaten und die können dann jeweils immer noch mal die Genehmigung zum Signieren von Zertifikaten delegieren. Und dann hast du quasi eine Kette, die hochgeht, was weiß ich, bis auf die Ebene deines Staates oder vielleicht sogar bis auf die Ebene der EU, je nachdem, was du jetzt gerade verifizierst, ob du im eigenen Land oder im Ausland usw. Das wird dann kompliziert, aber grundsätzlich ist es immer nur das Prüfen einer Signaturkette. Dass dir ein Signaturzertifikat oder dir geheime Schlüssel davon abhanden kommt, das musst du einplanen. Und die Kontingenzpläne, die du dafür hast, sind folgende. Erstens könnte es sein, ein einzelner Impfpass wird ausgestellt, der unberechtigt ist. Dann könntest du den spezifischen einen Impfpass revoken, also zurückrufen. Dafür hast du eine CRL, eine Certificate Revocation List. Da haust du die Prüf-Summen von ungültigen Zertifikaten rein und signierst die wieder, mit denen du die Aussage triffst, ja, ich hab mal gesagt, dass der gültig ist, für sechs Monate oder ein Jahr. Aber hiermit sage ich, dass das nicht mehr der Fall ist. Die nächste Möglichkeit ist, wenn dir das hier passiert, dass du dann eben einzelne Zertifikate, diese Zertifikate, die gefälschte unterschrieben haben, ungültig machst. Also du sagst nicht nur dieser eine Impfpass ist ungültig, sondern alle, die mit diesem Zertifikat signiert wurden. Und dafür musst du aber natürlich dann dafür sorgen, dass dieses Signatur-Zertifikat möglichst häufig sich wechselt. Mir ist nicht ganz klar, was die hier gemacht haben. Und ich befürchte, dass sie die vielleicht doch nicht so oft gewechselt haben oder so viele unterschiedliche genommen haben. Jedenfalls war es zu Beginn des Launches dieser Greenpass-Infrastruktur in Deutschland und Europa so, dass sie nicht einen spezifischen Revocation-Prozess überhaupt hatten. Und vor allem, weil sie den nicht haben, haben sie jetzt das Problem, dass zwar die italienische Nachrichtenagentur sagt, dass sie diese geheimen Schlüsse, mit denen das gefälschte Zertifikat erstellt wurde, zurückgerufen haben. Das heißt, eben alle anderen, die damit signiert wurden, sind jetzt auch ungültig, sagen aber nicht, wie viele das sind. Und gleichzeitig wird aber jetzt in der deutschen COFPASS-Check-App, zumindest Zeitpunkt gestern, das Zertifikat noch als gültig angezeigt. Ja, also es sieht offenbar jetzt also danach aus, dass die nicht so wirklich sich darüber Gedanken gemacht haben, wie diese Revocation halt gut läuft. Und vor allem das nicht vereinheitlicht haben. Das war auch mein Eindruck aus den Gesprächen damals, als der ganze Kram online ging. Wie groß der Schaden jetzt ist, werden wir noch sehen. Aber dieser Fall, dass der eintreten würde, muss vorgesehen sein. Du darfst es nicht so bauen, dass du davon ausgehst, dass dir sowas nicht passiert. Und ich denke, die Bewertungsdimension ist jetzt, wie viele Impfpässe müssen sie jetzt ungültig machen, weil sie mit diesem offensichtlich kompromittierten Zertifikat signiert wurden. Und damit leider jetzt als ungültig zu betrachten sind, unabhängig davon, ob sie tatsächlich ungültig sind oder vor einem potenziellen Diebstahl, oder Abhandenkommen oder Kompromittierung dieses Schlüssels signiert wurden. Muss man mal sehen, wie das läuft. Es wird auf jeden Fall spannend zu erfahren, wie die Angreifer an diese Keys gekommen sind. Das sollte eigentlich natürlich nicht möglich sein. Und dann mal gucken, wie viele sie jetzt ungültig machen müssen deshalb.
Wir hatten ja hier, als diese ganze Impfpass-Diskussion war, mal so ein bisschen im Kopf durchgerechnet, wie lange das jetzt dauert, das alles auszurollen etc. Und sind ja da erstmal auf sehr lange Zeiträume gekommen. Und dann ging ja alles ganz schnell.
Genau, das ging aber schnell, weil sie den Signaturteil im Prinzip aufs Server bewegt haben und nicht den Apotheken eigenes Schlüsselmaterial gegeben haben. Und dann hatten sie ja auch noch quasi die Authentifizierung auf der Ebene schwach gemacht, wo es dann eben ja auch noch die Demonstrationen gab, dass man sich relativ einfach als Apotheke registrieren konnte.
Genau, also es ist Zeit gespart worden, indem man einfach nicht ausreichend nachgedacht hat, welche Konsequenzen die Struktur hat, die man da ausrollt. Und das erklärt es ein wenig, macht es aber nicht besser. Das ist einfach ein Problem, zumal ja eben auch in der ganzen Debatte, wir jetzt, jetzt haben wir, jetzt stehen wir vor der vierten Welle oder wir stehen mittendrin, kann man sagen. Es sind halt viele nicht geimpft. Wir haben teilweise 2G-Systematiken, wo dann gesagt wird, na ja, aber bei 2G können ja nur Geimpfte sein. Aber wenn dann eben dieses Impfpass-Regime dann so lax ist, ist das natürlich dann auch eine akute Gefährdung der Leute. Und das ist halt das, was ich nicht so richtig verstehen kann. Dass wenn man jetzt wirklich schon sagt, ok, alles klar, auf der Basis versuchen wir zumindest den Teil, der bereit ist, sich für sich und andere zu schützen, auch die Freiheiten wiederzugeben, dass das dann dadurch torpediert wird, dass das einfach technisch nicht ordentlich umgesetzt wird, abgesehen davon, dass, ich weiß nicht, welche Erfahrungen du gemacht hast, ohnehin diese ganzen Impfpässe so lax geprüft werden, wenn überhaupt. Also ich war jetzt bei verschiedensten Veranstaltungen und hab alles gesehen von, keiner wollte was sehen, man war zufrieden, wenn man irgendwas QR-Code-artiges in der Hand hatte. Also ich hab sogar schon meinen laminierten QR-Code einfach nur in der Luft gewädelt, ohne weitere Erklärungen, ohne dass da ein Name drauf steht. Also lesbar, für Menschen lesbar. Dann halt diese Display-Scroller, die sie zumindest noch irgendwie sehen wollen, dass das jetzt auch wirklich eine App ist, aber wessen QR-Code da angezeigt wird, dann auch nicht interessiert. Und selten wird dann mal gescannt. Und dann gibt's halt noch die Leute, die scannen, aber dann eben die Daten nicht überprüfen. Ich würde mal fast sagen, derzeit in 80 bis 90 Prozent der Fälle würde man sogar noch mit irgendeinem QR-Code oder gar keinem QR-Code durchkommen.
Das habe ich aber damals zum Launch dieses Dings im ZDF-Interview gesagt. Habe ich gesagt, niemand wird sich Stress machen bei der Prüfung dieser Impfpässe. In diesem Live-Interview bin ich kurz daran vorbeigeschrammt, die reißen sich doch hier nicht mit ihnen Stress ein oder sowas. Das ist genau. Der Punkt. Niemand hat ein Interesse an der genauen Prüfung dieser Zertifikate. Das war immer meine Vorhersage und das ist ja auch klar. Ich glaube, ein-, zweimal bin ich in ein Hotel eingecheckt. Und da war dann, weil sie ja eh dann quasi den Namen sehen beim Check-In. Ich glaube, ein einziges Mal wurde ich auch tatsächlich nach dem Personalausweis noch dazu gefragt. Aber ja, ich bin jetzt auch nicht, also ich würde immer noch sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich ganz gut, dass es nicht so krass überprüft wird, weil die, wenn es anders wäre, wäre das glaube ich auch, würde das zu sehr viel Unmut führen. Aber weißt du, was sehr unterhaltsam ist, Tim? Du kannst, ich habe jetzt hier kürzlich ein neues Telefon gehabt, ja, und dann musste ich irgendwie umziehen. Und da habe ich gesehen, dass in der Corona-Warn-App jetzt mein Impf-Zertifikat nicht mit umgezogen ist. Ja, und weißt du, was ich dann gemacht habe? Da habe ich einfach mein altes Telefon genommen, habe gesagt, hier zeige ich mal Impf-Zertifikat an, habe das neue Telefon genommen und habe gesagt, importier mal. Und dann hat er natürlich mein Impf-Zertifikat einfach übernommen. Das heißt, der Prozess, zeige ich mal dein Impf-Zertifikat, ich scanne mal den QR-Code, das ist im Prinzip alles, was du brauchst, um jemand anders sein Impf-Zertifikat zu klauen.
Wo da natürlich ein anderer Name dran steht.
Ja genau, was ja aber wiederum keine Sau interessiert. Und die Verwirrung mit COFPASS und COFPASS-Check ist der Gestalt, dass ein Freund von mir, der eine Kneipe betreibt, dann irgendwie so, und jetzt nicht, sage ich mal, der digital native ist, der hat sich quasi auch so eine App runtergeladen und rief mich nach ein paar Stunden an und sagte, ey Linus, diese ganzen Impfpässe, die werden da drin gespeichert. Und ich sagte, nee, das kann nicht sein. Das kann nicht sein, dass die gespeichert werden.
Er hat die alle importiert.
Und er sagte, das kann doch nicht sein, Datenschutz. Dieser Prozess, den hat halt niemand verstanden. Niemand hat das verstanden. Ich hab's ja auch mal erklärt. Ich hab's ja öfter mal erklärt. Ich muss jetzt dazu sagen, ich finde, dass du einfach wirklich, dass der Prozess, dass du wirklich so ein angezeigtes Zertifikat trotzdem einfach sofort wieder importieren kannst, ich finde, das hätte man anders machen sollen. Da hätte man zumindest noch in den QR-Code einfach mit reinschreiben können. Ich zeige das hier gerade an zur Verifikation, damit jetzt zumindest irgendwie eine Standard-App nicht sofort diesen Impfpass auch dann importiert. Damit ist das Problem nicht aus der Welt, weil du relativ simpel eine bauen kannst, die es trotzdem macht, und du kannst sie ja auch einfach kopieren und so weiter. Aber das ist eben auch nun mal die Eigenschaft des Impfausweises wie jeder andere auch. Das wäre bei dem Gelben genauso. Der ist nichts wert ohne einen Vergleich mit dem Personalausweis und so weiter und so fort. Alles hundertmal erklärt. Und es ist klar, dass es niemand ordentlich macht. Und entsprechend kannst du wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ja gut, dann sind jetzt halt auch noch gefälscht im Umlauf. Hauptsache Telekom und SAP haben ihre Millionen kassiert. Ich meine, ich bleibe ja dabei, dass ich jetzt insgesamt kein großer Fan der Gesamtidee Impfpasskontrolle bin. Gleichzeitig mich gestern auch nochmal darüber unterhalten. Will man jetzt diesen kalten Impfzwang, will man darauf setzen, dass man sagt, ihr kommt jetzt irgendwo nicht mehr rein, was letztendlich auch Reaktanz erhöht und die Motivation, sich gefälschte Impfpässe zu holen. Realistisch ist das Schlimmste, was dir passiert, wenn du jetzt mit dem Impfpass vom Kumpel versuchst, in irgendein Restaurant zu kommen. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Person, die da vorne steht, bei der du dann sagst, ich bin nun mal der Markus, haste nicht gesehen, ich hab halt meinen Ausweis nicht dabei, tut mir leid, dass die sagt, okay, da musst du jetzt gehen. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist eh schon weit unter 1%. Und wenn du an diese 1% an Leuten gerätst, die dann ernsthaft sagen, geh bitte, dann bin ich mal gespannt, wie viel Prozent von denen auch noch sagen würden, oh mein Gott, das ist hier ein Enttäuschungsversuch, ich ruf die Bullen. Und dann ist noch die Frage, ob es überhaupt strafbar ist, einen falschen Impfpass zu zeigen oder nicht.
Und ob das nachgewiesen werden kann, dass das jetzt absichtlich geschehen ist in dem Moment, ja, ne, habe ich falsch verstanden.
Genau, ach Mist, habe ich das falsche Handy eingesteckt. Ich bin ja gar nicht geimpft. Und jetzt wäre die andere Frage, wenn du jetzt sagst, du willst die Impfquote erhöhen, kannst du halt mit negativen Anreizen das versuchen. Du kannst aber auch positive Anreize geben, wie wir hier gescherzt haben mit der Bratwurst. Da haben wir uns noch drüber lustig gemacht, weil wir jederzeit lieber die Impfung als die Bratwurst genommen hätten. Jetzt gibt es Leute, die zweifeln, wie diesen Fußballer, der dieser Kimmich oder wie der heißt. Sehr interessant, klingt halt erst mal komisch, aber wenn du einfach sagst, alles klar, hier kriegst du noch ein Fuffi zur Impfung, was meinst du, wie viele Leute das machen würden? Und ich glaube, dass du damit halt, ich meine, dann hast du die Querdenker, die dann sagen, ja, die Menschenversuche 50 Euro ist viel zu wenig für einen Menschenversuch, aber immerhin kriegst du mal Geld für deinen Menschenversuch. Muss man doch auch mal positiv sehen. Und diese Diktaturvorstellungen, die dann da sind, denen hätte man halt auch sehr viel Wind aus dem Segel nehmen können, wenn man eben mehr auf positive Anreize gesetzt hätte als auf negative.
Ja, es ist nämlich selten, dass in Diktaturen die Leute für ihre Folter auch noch bezahlt werden.
Ja, allerdings in einer GmbH-Diktatur natürlich dann schon. Okay, dann haben die Reporter ohne Grenzen noch eine Klage eingereicht oder direkt mehrere. Und zwar die Reporter ohne Grenzen als Vereinigung mit Investigativjournalistinnen und Journalisten und dem Whistleblower-Netzwerk klagen sie gegen die neuen Staatstrojaner Befugnisse für Geheimdienste. Die wurden ja im Juni quasi verabschiedet, wo gesagt wird, jetzt haben alle Nachrichtendienste die Möglichkeit mittels Space-Software in Smartphones und Computer einzudringen und verschlüsselte Nachrichten abzuhören. Also Staatstrojaner für Geheimdienste. Wichtig, immer im Hinterkopf behalten, der Unterschied zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten ist, Polizei muss sich potenziell irgendwann einmal für den Einsatz rechtfertigen und sammelt Beweise gegen dich. Und der Geheimdienst muss sich im Zweifelsfall nie rechtfertigen. Und damit hast du halt auch dann keine nennenswerten Möglichkeiten zur Feststellung, dass die Maßnahme nicht rechtens war, die gegen dich ergriffen wurde. So, jetzt argumentieren Reporter ohne Grenzen, dass in dieser Ausweitung dieser Beflugnisse auf die Nachrichtendienste keinerlei Berücksichtigung von Journalistinnen und Journalistinnen ihren Quellen ist, die also damit auch Ziel solcher Maßnahmen werden können und dürfen. Und das ist natürlich ein schwerwiegender Eingriff in das Redaktionsgeheimnis. Und entsprechend klagen sie dagegen. Christian Mier, der Geschäftsführer von Reporter ohne Grenzen, sagte, dieses Gesetz ist auch ein Eingriff auf den Informantenschutz im digitalen Raum. Was auf den ersten Blick aussieht wie eine Nebensächlichkeit, kann große Konsequenzen für investigativ arbeitende Journalistinnen und Journalisten haben. Einmal mehr ziehen wir gegen ein Gesetz vor Gericht, das Sachverständige für verfassungswidrig erklärt haben und das dennoch über alt und ohne Rücksicht auf die Folgen für Journalismus und Pressefreiheit in Deutschland verabschiedet wurde. Hat er recht. Und kann man natürlich eigentlich hoffen, dass diese Klage durchaus Aussicht auf Erfolg hat, weil wenn du jetzt irgendwie die Befugnisse deiner Geheimdienste über die Pressefreiheit stellst, dann bist du halt wirklich ein bisschen weit gegangen.
Ja, gibt aber auch durchaus Leute, die das schon lange so sehen, dass dem so ist.
Aber jede einzelne Klage gegen Staatstrojanereinsatz ist eine wichtige und eine richtige. Und deswegen begrüße ich das sehr, dass hier die Reporter ohne Grenzen mit dem Whistleblower-Netzwerk sich gegen diese Sache zu wehrsetzen. Machen die ja auch nicht zum ersten Mal. Jetzt sind wir am Ende, Mitte nächster Woche. Ich schaue gerade schon in den Shop, er macht Fortschritte. Und da wird es dann schöne T-Shirts geben und Hoodies vielleicht auch. Können wir eigentlich auch mal anbieten. Den bestücken wir und dann könnt ihr so am 3. November abends, denke ich, mal schauen, ob ihr euch bekleiden möchtet, ob ihr Werbekunde bei uns werden möchtet.
Genau, dazu dann nächste Woche mehr von uns. Und zwischendurch wisst ihr, ihr könnt ja immer auf Twitter gucken. Entweder folgt da Linus, et Linuzifa, oder mir, et Tim Pritlove.
Oder dem Netzpolitik-Account, ME, unterstrich.
Bewerbe gerade unsere Twitter-Accounts.
Ja, ich möchte aber auch, dass mein Instagram-Account beworben wird.
Und wie ist der?
Ich hab nämlich ein Instagram-Account gemacht, ursprünglich einfach mal um sicherzustellen, dass mir den Platz da keiner wegnimmt. Aber ich war ein der großen Kunstwerke in Hamburg dieser Zeit. Kennst du diese Story? Das müssen wir eigentlich noch erzählen. Andy! Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das überhaupt behandelt hatten. Also die Geschichte geht so. Hamburg hat einen Innensenator. Dieser Innensenator heißt Andy Grote. Und der hat wohl auch irgendetwas getwittert, was eine sehr große Janusköpfigkeit zum Ausdruck gebracht hat. Und darauf hat jemand mit einem sehr kleinen Twitter-Account geantwortet. Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel.
Ein Pimmel.
Oder so ein Pimmel. Also eine Eins statt ein Ein. Und jetzt kann man, so die meisten Leute, haben dann die Größe, über so etwas hinwegzusehen. Aber manche Leute sind eben, ich glaube, das nennt man fragile Männlichkeit, reagieren bei so etwas sehr empfindlich. Aus welchem Grund auch immer. Und der Andy-Senator, der Innen-Senator Andy Grote von Hamburg, reagiert eben bei so etwas empfindlich. Und deswegen hat er dann einen Strafantrag wegen Beleidigung gestellt. Und da wollte natürlich dann die Polizei, die ihm ja untersteht, zeigen, dass sie ihre Arbeit richtig gut machen kann. Und haben dann eine Hausdurchsuchung anberaumt. In dem Fall dann der Freundin des Angezeigten auf der Suche nach dem Tatmittel. Als bräuchte man jetzt noch irgendwelche großen Beweise, dass dieser Mensch diesen Tweet abgesetzt hat. Also Hausdurchsuchung wegen eines Tweets. So, großes Gelächter und das hatte dann etwas zur Folge, was als Pimmelgate inzwischen fester Bestandteil des Wikipedia-Artikels zum Streisandeffekt ist. Nämlich, dass sich vorher niemand für den Pimmel von Andy Grote interessiert hat. Wirklich niemand, außer eben Andy Grote. Und dieses Interesse jetzt eigentlich die Hansestadt Hamburg geradezu in ihren Bann gezogen hat. Irgendjemand hat dann Aufkleber gedruckt. So kleine neongelbe Aufkleber rund, wo drauf steht Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel. Und die wurden in St. Pauli geklebt. An verschiedene Stellen im öffentlichen Raum. St. Pauli ist offenbar der Wohnort von Andy, was dazu geführt hat, dass er mit seiner Pimmel konfrontiert wurde. Die Polizei hat dann im Rahmen der Gefahrenabwehr diese Aufkleber abgemacht. Du hast einen Polizisten, der durch St. Pauli rennt. Und die Gefahrabwehren, die von diesen Aufklebern ausgeht.
Die unglaubliche, gefährliche, große Gefahr von Aufklebern.
Unglaublich.
Wo ja noch nicht mal sein voller Name drauf steht. Es könnte ja jetzt irgendwelche Andys sein.
Und dann war auch wieder, ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher, ich glaube, da war dann auch wieder Staatsschutz ermittelt gegen Unbekannt, irgendein Scheiß. Also wieder das komplette Programm. Dann hat die Rote Flora ein seit Jahrzehnten besetztes Theater in Hamburg am Schulterblatt. Zentrale Anlaufstelle der Hamburger Linken. Die haben so eine Plakatwand. Und sie haben auf diese Plakatwand, glaube ich zwei sogar, auf die linke haben sie dann so Theatervorhänge gemacht. So rechts und links und rot und oben drüber. Dann haben sie ganz oben drauf geschrieben Soko Wand und Farbe. Und quasi hinter dem Vorhang, der ja dann offen ist, klebte dann sehr groß ein neongelber Kreis. In dem drin stand Andy, du bist so ein Spimmel. Was quasi einfach dieser Aufkleber war, den sie dann eben in Plakatgröße an ihr Gebäude geklebt haben. Jetzt muss man dazu wieder die Geschichte der Soko Wand und Farbe kennen, die damals in der Hafenstraße einen Schriftzug an einem Haus entfernen wollte, wo irgendwie, was weiß ich, Bullen oder sowas stand. Das wollten die wegmachen. Deswegen ist dann die Soko Wand und Farbe mit einem Hubwagen angereist und rollen mit schwarzer Farbe und haben dann an diesem Haus irgendwie die Wörter weggemalt, die ihnen nicht gefallen haben. Woraufhin die Bewohner mit einem Gartenschlauch aus dem Fenster diese Farbe einfach wieder abgespült haben, weil die Polizei wasserlös nicht mitgebracht hat. Und zu guter Letzt hat dann die rüstige Bewohnerschaft der Hafenstraße dieser Sachbeschädigung, die ihr im Haus angedeihen sollte, entgegengewirkt durch den Wurf von Farbe. In diesem Fall allerdings nicht wasserlösliche Farbe, die dann also die Uniformen der Polizistinnen kleideten. Und du hattest dann, da gibt es einen sehr schönen Fernsehbeitrag für den suche ich auch noch mal raus, indem wir die Show notes, so eine Situation, wie dann eben oben die Hafenstraßebewohner ihr Haus sauber machen, wo die schwarze Farbe einfach runterläuft und unten die Polizisten stehen mit ihrem Wasser wieder und versuchen ihre Uniform sauber zu machen, was aber nicht von Erfolg gekrönt ist. Das ist der Hintergrund von dieser Überschrift Soko Wand und Farbe. Und du hast also jetzt diesen großen runden Aufkleber auf dem Plakat, der halt da schon dran anspielt und mit diesem Vorhang ja auch sehr, mit mehreren Anspielungen die Spiele eröffnet. Und was passiert? Es ist tatsächlich, gibt die Polizei sich die Blöße, da mit einer schwarzen Rolle hinzugehen und dieses Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel an der roten Flora zu übermalen, als polizeiliche Maßnahme. Konsequenz, nächsten Tag steht da mit Sprühfarbe wieder Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel. Polizei kommt wieder mit ihrer schwarzen Farbe und malt da wieder drüber und jetzt steht da eben Andy, du bist so ein Pimmel, tritt zurück und oben links steht Flora 3, Bullen 2, also der Spielstand. Wie kannst du dich als Innensenator so zum Gespött der Leute machen? Außerdem hängt in Hamburg in mehreren Plakatkästen irgendwie so eine, ja im Prinzip sieht das aus wie so eine Spiegeltimmel-Seite, nur statt Spiegel steht oben Pimmel. Auf dem Cover ist dann halt der Innensenator Andy Grote und der Mann lässt sich jetzt mit Anlauf seit inzwischen Monaten durch den Kakao ziehen und du fragst dich ernsthaft, ob der denn irgendein Verständnis hat davon, dass er sich damit gerade, also der macht sich halt wirklich, zum Pimmel macht er sich. Der macht sich echt zum Pimmel, wenn er einfach diesen blöden Tweet ignoriert hätte oder diese blöden Aufkleber oder das Ding an der Flora, aber nein, immer wieder drauf, immer wieder drauf. Und jetzt gibt es halt Menschen, die bezeichnen den Hals als Pimmel-Andy. Das würde ich mir jetzt nicht zu eigen machen, eine derartige Bezeichnung, aber da muss man echt sagen, vielleicht sollte der mal zu so einer Richterin gehen, die ihm dann sagt, ja Herr Grote, vielleicht hören sie einfach auf. Das ist auf jeden Fall, würde ich sagen, ein Fall von Mobbing, der halt echt einfach nur von ihm selber angeheizt wird. Das hat er sich selber zuzuschreiben.
Absolut. Ich hätte trotzdem ganz gerne diese Ausgabe von dem Magazin, dem ehemaligen Nachrichtenmagazin der Pimmel, weil da sind wirklich interessante Artikel auch angekündigt. Streisand-Effekt, was wir alle von Andy lernen können. Patriarchat, Tipps zur Überwindung fragider Männlichkeit, Puller-Alarm, Staatsanwaltschaft und Polizei drehen frei. Und die Hauptstory, Mensch, Andy, sei doch nicht so steif.
Also an unsere lieben Freundinnen und Freunde in Hamburg, wenn da noch was über ist, zwei Plakate und ein paar Aufkleber wären bei uns in guten Händen. In Hamburg werden die ja eh die ganze Zeit abgerissen von der Polizei. Vielleicht haben wir in Berlin noch eine Chance. Nee, aber da würde ich mich sehr über Zuschriften freuen. Tims Versandadresse steht ja im Impressum unter metaebene.me.
Die Macher haben allerdings auch einen Twitter-Account. Das nervt jeden. Die Gruppe nennt sich Dies Irae, was so viel heißt wie Tag des Zorns.
Aber genau, das war dann mein Instagram-Launch, dass ich nämlich, als ich in Hamburg war, selbstverständlich auf Instagram macht man ja Selfies. Ich mache nicht so viele Selfies deswegen, weil diese Plattform für mich jetzt nie so interessant ist. Aber ich habe ein Foto vor der roten Flora gemacht. Und tatsächlich, so viel kann ich auch noch verraten, wir waren halt zu dritt vor der Tür und haben uns dann geräuschvoll erfreut. Und es dauerte nicht lange, bis oben aus dem Fenster Leute kamen, die quasi erstaunlich schnell bereit waren zur Verteidigung ihres Werkes. Und dann aber gesehen haben, dass von uns jetzt erstmal keine Gefahr ausging. Und wir waren jetzt auch nicht die Einzigen, die sich da angesammelt haben, um halt vor diesem einmaligen Werk zeitgenössischer Kunst ein Selfie zu machen. Schön, da ist das Internet dann doch immer wieder schön.
Manchmal ganz lustig. Ja, einfach um so ein bisschen Entlastung, mentale Entlastung zu schaffen. Auch wenn das natürlich am Ende nicht viel macht. Diese Soko-Wand und Farbe, das war mir ja auch neu, die gibt es ja offensichtlich auch schon seit Ewigkeiten. Das ist jetzt nichts, was jetzt neu eingeführt wurde, sondern es gab irgendwie 2008 schon so einen schönen extra drei Berichter drüber.
Das ist der, auf den ich mich bezogen habe.
Genau, und das ist im Wesentlichen dazu da, linke Parolen zu übertünchen, wenn ich das so richtig sehe. Da fragt man sich halt auch, so Hakenkreuze und so, könnte der dann nicht auch noch übernehmen? Gut, vielleicht malen die ja nochmal manches über. Aber ich erinnere mich auch wiederum an eine ältere Dame, war es in Dresden oder so, wo die gelebt hat, du kennst die Story wahrscheinlich auch, deren Hauptwerk das ist, irgendwie die ganze Zeit, Hakenkreuze zu übermalen und Nazi-Aufkleber abzumachen, die dann auch immer mal dafür verklagt wurde. Also das ist einfach alles so falsch und so schräg und so kaputt. Insofern muss ich sagen, ist dann auch mal so eine gehörige Trachtprüge in Form von Hämme und Sport auch mal ganz angemessen, dass ihr einfach auch mal merkt, wo die Grenzen eures überheblichen Handelns zu sein haben.
Es geht ja vor allem, also hier sind zwei Dinge mal relevant. Also erstens, wenn wir uns gerade noch über den Drachenlord unterhalten, da gibt es natürlich einen Unterschied zwischen dem Drachenlord und dem Innen-Senator der Hansestadt Hamburg oder des Stadtstaates Hamburg, besteht spezifisch darin, dass niemand, niemand die Gelegenheit hat, als Reaktion auf einen Tweet mit dem Inhalt, du bist so eins Pimmel, eine Hausdurchsuchung zu veranlassen bei der Urheberin des Tweets. Damit geht es los. Das ist hier das Kräfteverhältnis, von dem man reden muss. Wenn ich in den Drachenkanal gehe und unter ein YouTube-Video von dem schreibe, du bist so eins Pimmel, und er würde das zur Anzeige bringen, dann würden alle sagen, was willst du denn für einen vollen Idiot belästige die Polizei, bitte nicht damit. Sicherlich nicht, würde er bei mir eine Hausdurchsuchung schreiben.
Und du hättest 10.000 Follower mehr.
Ja, so und jetzt, damit geht es los. Das wiederum, muss man ja sehen, ist eine brachiale Machtdemonstration der Polizei und ein Missbrauch der Macht des Innensenators, dass er eben sich hier einen sehr viel besseren rechtlichen Schutz für seine fragile Männlichkeit sucht und gestattet, als zum Beispiel meiner fragilen Männlichkeit zugestanden würde. Und das ist der eigentliche Skandal hier. Dass der Protest dagegen oder die Illustration dessen in Form dieser Aufkleber und der Plakate und der Flora-Aktion stattfindet, ist kein Fall von Mobbing, sondern letztendlich ein Aufbäumen des Restes von uns, der Gesellschaft, gegen einen ganz eklatanten Machtmissbrauch und auch eine Geldverschwendung. Ich meine, da rennen jetzt Polizisten rum und kratzen irgendwelche Aufkleber ab. Wo sind wir denn? Wenn ihm die Aufkleber nicht gefallen, soll er die selber abmachen oder sich bei Helps da jemanden holen. Aber dafür jetzt auch noch hier die mit teuren Steuergeldern in Hamburg finanzierte Polizei zu vergeuden, das ist ja wirklich ein Skandal und den möchte ich hier wirklich nicht aus den Augen verlieren.
Genau, haben wir hiermit dann nicht getan. Hier wird alles angeprangert, was anzuprangern ist. Jetzt haben wir uns aber ausgeprangert. Oder?
Ja, Tim, du bist so ein Spimmel.
Na ja, du auch.
Zeig dich an.
Anzeige ist raus.
Also da muss ich natürlich auch sagen, es gibt immer einen, der beleidigt und einen, der sich beleidigen lässt.
Können nix ab.
Sag mal, steht in den Showdots jetzt wegen Autokorrektur, Andy, du bist so eins Himmel oder weil du Angst hast, dass wir auch eine Hausversuchung kriegen?
Nee, das war in der Tat Autokorrektur. Tja, sogar die Autokorrektur ist auf der Seite der Polizei. Soko-Autokorrektur.
So, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung. Genau, Twitter-Accounts folgen, Instagram keine Sorgen. Oh ja, jetzt kommen wir die Kommentare. Linus, dein Instagram-Account. Da freue ich mich schon oft.
Ich habe auch einen Instagram-Account, aber ich weiß nicht, wie viele Posts hast du da schon gemacht?
20 oder so.
Du bist schon richtig am Arbeiten, so Social Media-mäßig und so.
Ich möchte meine Reichweite in Richtung von Kindern und Jugendlichen ausbauen. Mit Facebook habe ich da einfach eine gute Partnerin.
Ich fühle mich jetzt herausgefordert, da auch irgendwie zu sein, weil ich mich ansonsten minderwertig fühle. Jetzt muss ich so sein wie du.
Guck mal, wie viel ich habe. Ich habe mehr Instagram-Posts. 36 Posts.
Mehr als was?
36 Posts auf Instagram habe ich gemacht.
Wahnsinn. Ich glaube, ich habe einen. Oder zwei. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau. Das erste war ein Test und das zweite auch. Ich wollte halt einfach wissen, ne stimmt gar nicht, ich habe vier. Ich habe vier. Vier. Na ja, kannst mal sehen, ich bin ganz schön ambitioniert. Du Social Media, kannst noch was lernen. Na ja, bin ja mehr so ein Twitter-Typ. Leute, wir entlassen euch.